i often draw strength from meeting
ordinary people doing extraordinary
things
elizabeth was the longest running
monarch in british history mother to
four children and grandmother to eight
she performed her public duties well
into her 90s i still view her more as
the queen than my grandmother you you
have this huge amount of respect for for
your boss and i always view her as my
boss but royal life slowed down for the
queen after she lost her beloved husband
prince philip in april of 2021 the
widowed monarch sat all alone at his
parent-down pandemic funeral the two had
been married for 73 years for me in the
months since the death of my beloved
philip
i have drawn great comfort from the
warmth and affection of the many
tributes to his life and work
[Music]
the queen carried on but began to look
frail and tired in october of 2021 she
spent a night in the hospital for an
undisclosed ailment concerned for her
health her majesty's doctors ordered her
to pause her public appearances and
arrest but determined to serve in
november of 2021 she made a video
statement to world leaders at the
glasgow climate summit the impact of the
environment on human progress
was a subject close to the heart of my
dear late husband after philip's death
elizabeth proved to be strong despite a
number of challenges in january of 2022
she stripped her son prince andrew of
his hrh title and all of his military
honors following his alleged involvement
in the jeffrey epstein scandal and a
related sexual assault lawsuit
the queen also had to deal with the
fallout from the harry and meghan makes
it drama i had
three conversations with my grandmother
and two conversations with my father
before he stopped taking my calls from
their bombshell sit down with oprah to
the couple's constant legal battles with
the press the monarch publicly continued
to voice support for the sussex clan who
named their daughter lillabet after the
queen's childhood nickname
viewed by many as serious and
old-fashioned she was actually quite
playful thank you mr prime minister of
canada for making me feel so old
good evening
[Applause]
[Music]
and remember this moment with harry that
quickly became a gif
hey prince harry remember when you told
us to bring it at the invictus games
careful what you wish for
boom
oh really
please
elizabeth was known for her love of her
corgis almost all of her outfits were
custom-made just for her in the 50s she
favored dresses cinched at the waist in
later years she went for coats and hats
always in bright colors so she could
stand out in a crowd
the priceless jewels and tiaras she wore
were historical family heirlooms
[Music]
but what the queen definitely valued was
her family she took great pleasure in
attending the royal weddings of her
grandsons william with kate and harry to
megan it's been a busy year for my
family with two weddings and two babies
and another child expected soon it helps
to keep a grandmother well occupied that
was baby archie and the queen appeared
overjoyed when she met her new
great-grandson for the first time
she beamed while watching prince george
make a christmas pudding and seemed very
proud watching charlotte and louie doing
the royal wave in fact many have noticed
that princess charlotte has a very
strong resemblance to her great granny
the queen she was really thrilled as a
little girl and i think as soon as we
came back here to to kensington she was
one of our first visitors here
i think she's very fond of
charlotte always watching what she's up
to georgia calls her gangan
she always leaves a little gift or
something in in that room when we're
going to go and stay and that just shows
i think her love for her her family the
queen never sat down for a formal tv
interview but she did allow cameras into
buckingham palace to record important
events on the 65th anniversary of her
coronation her majesty was quite cheeky
when viewing the imperial state crown
once you put it on it stays and you
can't look down to read the speech you
have to take the speech up
because if you did your neck would break
would it fall off
but what many admired was the royal love
story between elizabeth and prince
philip the couple's romantic
relationship and lavish wedding was
depicted in the crown
hi elizabeth alexandra mary
take thee
[Music]
the two were supportive of each other
and shared a love of the outdoors the
crown also portrayed their passion for
riding hiking and silly parlor games
number four it was two
she had a long connection with hollywood
giving some of the biggest stars titles
from dame elizabeth taylor to sir paul
mccartney and sir elton john she made
american citizen angelina jolie an
honorary dame of the british empire for
her work on behalf of refugees and we
love that she didn't seem phased at all
when she met lady gaga who happened to
be wearing a red rubber dress
and as the british people and millions
around the world mourn her majesty she
will always be remembered as a woman who
made and lived through history even in
the unlikeliest of places
hope can still be found
[Music]
you